boule care podcast
special guest the brothers are here
a cold day in hell ralphie the plug
draco the ruler
you gotta pick that mic up ralphie oh
yeah yeah
uh welcome man hey look first of all
y'all really look the [ __ ] alike
that was the life flex like it seemed
like a lot of people from out of town
they already know
but everybody from the city they
actually confused and [ __ ] how often do
you get confused for him
ralphie i don't know they know who i am
but i'm saying like you ever just be in
the mall somewhere
you got the jewelry on and [ __ ] they'd
be like oh [ __ ] does that happen
sometimes but but the word is like night
time too they know who i am because uh
just because at first they didn't even
know like we was even
related right right right exactly we
were just like
two different people like i don't know
um um
talk about uh this you know obviously
you guys are brothers doing album
together that had to come naturally but
like
how how long has this been in the works
like when did this idea originally first
first happen you know we've been talking
about it but you know they could be
we'd be in jail and [ __ ] so [ __ ] either
he'd go to jail or
[ __ ] they could go to jail or some weird
should happen but
the music being [ __ ] been making the
music ralphie what you
what because i know you were talking
outside about like you've been going
crazy since you got out when's the last
time you were locked up
oh [ __ ] like seven months ago like seven
months ago how long how long were you in
for
like three years oh [ __ ] so you guys are
locked up a lot at the same time
same place or no he was in jail before
us during the violation
and then they was you know [ __ ]
[ __ ]
hey we got a um appearance in the
interview
uh yeah he's he's turnt up for sure yeah
um were you guys in this were you guys
ever locked up at the same place ever
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah would they keep
you guys separated on like purpose
yeah uh huh yeah they came to us and uh
well they can't fight
they can't everything me they put him in
high power after a while they like [ __ ]
that we don't even want him walking
around he's too much
of a problem when you say a problem like
what what
when you when you're how do you how are
you a problem in jail like what are the
things
because he's so famous and everybody
wants to get a piece of mr famous draco
so
you know everybody wanna oh let me squat
let me squat there's too much commotion
they like uh you know
and then he's just too high power you
know yeah yeah
the police start doing all this [ __ ]
because it's [ __ ] he tweet anything
and then they go [ __ ] blow [ __ ] out
of proportion and now
detective janky detective go bring it to
the court and then now she
do something what she did she did some
weird [ __ ] yeah she got my
brother she got all his privileges
talking and [ __ ] all that type of [ __ ]
for tweeting how do you you were
tweeting it like
like you how you didn't even say nothing
either he said some [ __ ] like often stop
rapping they were trying to like take my
career or something from me and then
the fans just started going crazy oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] ass
and then that next you know they took it
out on him and put him in high power
oh so that's is that like solitary are
you in the box
yeah 23 1 that's as far as it gets
it was four by six
years or something 23 hours a day 24
hours a day so you
but what i mean they don't let you have
to wash your ass shower but it's gonna
be that long
you gotta you gotta shower damn near
everybody else that get them same in my
hour so you bought you the
time you come out this is like a little
quick little [ __ ] shower
hey draco being in a 4x6 cell 24 hours a
day
right that's got to be mentally [ __ ]
what you mean oh yeah
crazy like do you kind of go crazy that
you like i feel like
it's kind of hard to be the same when
you come out from that yeah
all you got is your thoughts that's all
you got
okay how'd you get through that man
i need to stay on the phone all [ __ ]
days see not down there
oh yeah you know no phone [ __ ] are you
talking about
that's when you wasn't in there you were
uh all day every time i
called his knee on the phone but uh just
like
reading books and working out
and listening to the radio i guess
because it ain't really too much else to
do that's crazy
listen to other people talk all day long
about
[ __ ] you just hear people screaming from
their cell y'all tell us
that's crazy yeah i can't even imagine
man that's got to be like
i feel like like i don't know how that
really rehabilitates anybody you know
what i'm saying
crazy like that gotta make anybody like
i don't care who you are you can't come
out
from that and and be the same yeah like
bro
they know what they doing that's why so
many smokers to go to ten day flashes
i've seen it come five times my whole
time my the whole time i was in the
county i've seen them come five times
i'm like pause get these [ __ ] type of
[ __ ] like 10-day flashes and
and violations but they always want to
hit a [ __ ] this is my first case they
tried to do me like i was john gotti man
oh my god damn that is crazy
like my whole time this is my first life
right right first time yeah
god damn uh you you mentioned reading uh
draco what books did you uh
kind of like that kind of helped get you
through uh at that time
all right um i think
napoleon hill ought to read y'all mine
here so use it hey
napoleon hill is your guy
all right jailbrook is that what they
said jail books those are the ones
that's in there [ __ ] that's trying to
rehabilitate
get their thoughts right in these
sharpers right jail books
then you got the irvings and [ __ ] you
know everybody out there
well you said what is an urban it's like
an urban novel yeah like
like like basically a book that kind of
that's like written like a movie to wear
like some hood [ __ ] like a hood movie
like
yeah i can't read that it's like a hood
i was reading them off i was like no
sister soldiers and all the little shits
damn that's crazy you can't even like uh
like can't even like get a maxum
magazine in there nothing right like do
they consider that like bad if it's like
a [ __ ] in a bikini
and okay okay but not yeah i mean
certain [ __ ] got it but
other than that you don't know um
well no there's something floating
around [ __ ] that came down from the
pen and [ __ ] but right right
huh um a cold day in hell
right draco how many is this is this
project number
three or four for you since you've been
out yes
fifth project since you got out and i
talked to you
i don't even know when that was and you
had just dropped the first one
and it was and i it was like it felt
like two or three weeks after
i was like [ __ ] they'll be ready for
that and then the output is incredible
[ __ ] his version of industry [ __ ]
is is uh we know the truth like that's
draco industry [ __ ]
i mean that's it's far that's that's
just me knowing his rap style
to me that's how far i think it's gonna
go that's fair
like listening to his approach coming
off right am i right yeah he's gonna
come off
what did you learn um from him as far as
you know obviously you being you go you
know you're in his shadow
you know what i'm saying um what have
you taken from him
and applied to your own you know style
and and how you record and how you write
and all that [ __ ]
other than the lady [ __ ] the fast coming
up with the crafty [ __ ]
he'd be coming over [ __ ] like five
minutes like he gonna listen to a brand
we used to be like young knees
go listen to a beat and then come back
like with a whole like whole damn near
20-something bars just like easy in five
minutes or whatever b
he felt like listening to draco you
write him down like in your phone or
you're just off the top of the head
again i don't be having time to really
write [ __ ] like that
sometimes i do but i'll be punching in
now though
did um the drake record obviously was an
incredible look as an independent artist
in los angeles
i don't know many people who are
independent that get the drake record
because usually he might find someone
that's independent but that song is
going to come out through ovo
as a one-off he ain't gonna let him just
right with that [ __ ]
you you got it in this outing um yeah
i mean i think that's one of the biggest
looks you know
in l.a in a long time man yeah that says
a lot
uh you mentioned being in the club with
him and [ __ ]
how's your relationship with drake like
like you know a lot of people kind of
just
talking to him i just seen him yesterday
in traffic that's the crazy part
that's funny but yeah he's straight down
i'll be talking to him um i know you we
were talking outside about
the potential of doing a music video for
this record yeah
but you take it over the top i think
what is the uh what's going on with that
uh
i'm just waiting for him he was telling
me he went
right to the treatment so he's gonna see
you're gonna let drake handle the
treatment
are you gonna do it i mean that's a
beautiful thing right there yeah
tk was saying too uh you're chapped in
with detroit heavy
you you
like one song or something like one or
two songs maybe
one or two that's it what's um
you know vez was a real dope dude i met
him a few times he seems like you know
i'm real tight with his cousin adrian
swish
yeah um what what is uh i guess
the chemistry between detroit and the
west coast i feel like there's something
about it
like i feel like detroit functions so
hard with cali and vice versa
yeah that's probably what it is dripping
into the flu flaming and re-rocking
[ __ ] and scamming and [ __ ] we on the
same type of [ __ ] it's just
we probably flock a little bit more than
they
you feel me sell dope right right like
that's the other thing you know we so
dope but that was
not me personally but that was back in
the 80s [ __ ] was coming [ __ ] waiting
it ain't coming like that in 2021 like
these young [ __ ] is going in houses
and doing crazy
also shout out to everybody who isn't
going into houses and instead is
cracking the government right now
running up the edd i'd rather have them
run up the edd then run up in your crib
you know what i'm saying
just you know they can't they they can't
do that for long because it's over with
a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] ain't learning
i ain't showing you how to do the other
[ __ ] ain't letting you eat no more
you really that's how [ __ ] be though
there's so many people eating
like people who out and i got out [ __ ]
i got out everybody was up uncomfortable
like 80 people
right like yo pandemic hitting everyone
here to live
i'm fresh out to nothing i'm like oh
yeah [ __ ] going crazy i gotta get on
my [ __ ]
yeah i saw uh something came out that uh
imagine if you met jesus christ right
when he was born the day he was born
and in in from that day to now every day
you made a million dollars
you still wouldn't make the amount of
money the government just printed for
this
because it's like something like 770
billion dollars you would have made and
the government did 1.4 trillion
that's a good logic to make a broker
they want to go get some more money
every day
facts yeah see my [ __ ] don't be you
just need like damn ramadan or something
like they don't want to eat uh how i see
i mean obviously uh
draco you're walking around with a uh
substantial amount of uh
fetia yourself um what do you i mean
obviously since you got out of jail man
you know you're a really smart guy your
team is real smart shout out to tk
what are you doing um you know the real
estate market is booming there's so much
[ __ ] going on are you putting your money
in any different spots
or you're just buying more jewelry
because this is a lot more jewelry than
the last time
i'm putting more into stocks and like
[ __ ] like that this this [ __ ] i'll be
trying to tell him he
i'll be born by a little you feel me
dropping a hundred two hundreds
everywhere
you know little bitcoin this [ __ ] got
the money gonna buy a whole bitcoin like
you could buy it i don't even know how
many bitcoins you can get with that go
on dodge queen go crazy oh yeah yeah
yeah
he don't want to eat that'd be like this
[ __ ] crazy i told him he can go buy
like
go drop 20 on a couple little houses and
get aaron b to be the [ __ ] yeah
hey man it's so i mean look it's your
money you're gonna do what you want but
you can't hey i tell you what you can't
take it with you
that's i mean that's some real [ __ ] your
family good you're good you're
comfortable as long as you're happy
but so you're you're [ __ ] with the
the crypto yeah i'll be [ __ ] wrong
i'll just be
i don't know how to work it i'll just be
throwing a little 50s right
right right let's see what happens with
it
i should be lighting up all green though
oh my [ __ ] everything it'd be like 15
greens and like three oranges and [ __ ]
that's
all i know i know i'm winning you know
robert robin hood yeah yeah yeah
hey shout out to robin hood because that
[ __ ] just made it so easy that's why
there's another thing [ __ ]
it's like a [ __ ] it's like a social
media app you just log on
like you're buying i feel like there's
too many hood [ __ ] talking about bro
they go they gonna crash that [ __ ] you
gotta get hey we gotta get these
come on man it's bro i got out of jail
bro it's way too many [ __ ] in the hood
talking about some
yeah i just put 10 vans into stocks and
[ __ ] i'm like
hey that's hey but that's good no it's
good but [ __ ] i feel like
this is going to be overloading the
system or something there's gonna be a
glitch somewhere
they they ain't gonna want us to win
that much we gotta get dirt
hey draco don't miss it though draco you
gotta get you gotta get in the be
at least a little bit in that bitcoin
game i was thinking about it
bro if you if you drop the draco uh nft
fan you'll make a million bro
like that's something y'all y'all got it
bro so uh tory lanez just did it
and and he's quote unquote canceled then
that [ __ ]
went crazy like you know what i'm saying
i'm not saying i can't i'm just saying
like you know the industry is canceled
tory
good people but but he did the nft and
and uh
i think he did like one point something
a million like the dude he cracked him
even if you do a 500 off of something
that isn't even real
it's like nothing you can touch it's
literally like a digital
bro you could drop a song as an nft
and just how does that work
you i'll connect you with some people my
boy did does all of the uh
nft [ __ ] for a lot of the but yeah yeah
you could like literally you could tell
your fans i'ma put out a song as an nft
and there's gonna be one of one so the
only one person
will have the song they have to buy that
nft and the bids will go up
like six free i promise you bro [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] a hundred percent man
draco so look man i loved you on
that's what i tell everybody who's not
from here i say draco's the hottest
rapper
blast is the hottest singer
you guys you guys came together on his
project
on the deluxe um well yeah i'm gonna say
right now
i'm gonna say right there's a couple of
[ __ ] i would say right now
until greedy right now though
yeah right now right now blast got it
right here
no right now blast i mean rodney ain't
dropped since then end of 2019
come on right now and of course if roddy
rich drops tomorrow
there's not even a conversation let's be
let's they're both incredible and blast
will get there
but i thought it was dope that y'all
came together just i i feel
i felt like okay this this had to happen
was there a situation where you did one
for him and he did one for you
like y'all got more than one song uh i
just told him too
i just haven't idiot because i've been
yeah yeah on the e42 short [ __ ] yeah we
just shot the video for that
don't forget it was like two three days
oh you i feel like you got to get the
blast
a blast hook on your [ __ ] man it would
be crazy
yeah now i think that'd be uh who else
obviously you got
stink team so um you know i was
talking to tk outside he kind of
compared you to like the gucci mane in
la when it when it comes to the a
r [ __ ] when it comes to having it having
your ear to you know
the new talent for it um
so you know you got the label give me a
you know what's what's think team
give me the original origins of the name
the you know who's a part of it and
and all that good [ __ ] i mean it's me
my brother was
catchy ya
good finess
mom say so he's so burnt out right now
get it together then i'm thinking about
a couple of other people
uh damon i'm trying to get a little nine
right now though that's about it right
now
and shout out uh you got a situation
with uh for
for the labels with empire right and uh
some other people no well would you just
say he said oh no
we're talking his back catalog the back
catalog yeah
yeah shout out to ghazi though so what
do you like uh
when it comes to somebody who you want
to sign right what is like the main
thing
like the main attribute of a new artist
that you're looking for and they got to
be hard he got to be honest
he can't just be regular ain't got to be
able to just make [ __ ] it's just as fast
as we make our [ __ ] because
he will need no flops we need a [ __ ]
that can make a slapper
cause we record too fast we're recording
[ __ ] class
like just like good [ __ ] in like 10
minutes like no cap
like 10 20 minutes like a whole like me
i can record a hook in a verse in like
15 minutes
no cat 16 easy yeah i'm like
just punch in he said i'm like five he
liked the same amount of time unless he
got it written down already
he said i'm like i've been faster than
all these [ __ ] i'm like 10 minutes
really really who who raps first
depending on whoever feeling no no who
rapped first
in life oh yeah okay we always like
do you feel me bush and high young men
right right right right
but he was rapping first like his little
youtube [ __ ] from like
thousand four four twelve them there
freestyles and [ __ ]
that [ __ ] don't even know about he
being hard as a [ __ ] right and
we've been flying like been doing the
same [ __ ]
hey what up man how to interrupt the
bootleg cab podcast to tell you
about our good friends at odd socks
alright
yo shout out to them for sponsoring the
podcast but also we're being
such a fire company and they just
introduced
their draws that's right
odd socks now got your boxer briefs on
deck
some tapatio joints and then of course
they got the best socks in the game
look at these stone cold socks look at
these two i mean look
i love froot loops but i love these
froot loop socks these are fire i'm
taking those for myself
they got all the licenses breaking bad
mac dre
odb wwe street fighter whatever you want
they got
including these draws i love these draws
i got some on right now
so listen tap in with odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev and you will
save 20
off at checkout so oddsoxofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev
save 20 to check out and thank me later
hey i've been seeing you
pretty much hop on uh i mean [ __ ] man
my homies mexican and i know you did
this this
straight bond ass rancho humid lay
record
uh i forget the artist's name but it's
the whole song's in [ __ ] spanish and
then you're rap but it's like not like
spanish like reggaeton it's like some
real like
you said oh [ __ ]
and that [ __ ] came out hard as [ __ ] it
wasn't like no regular like i was like
this [ __ ] is crazy
um what is the if if someone's watching
this
and let's say the music is ass juice
right but they got they got a dope
dealer behind them so they got a bag and
they just want to
they want a draco verse what's what's
the ticket for that
it depends the song is trash though it's
not a good song
they want you to do the video and the
verse
but they got money that's the high uh
that's like 50. yeah
50 piece 50 piece
we got to bring the dawn out oh yeah
yeah that's like 50. that's a 50 piece
no video will we cut that in half
you give me 30.
i still got to put my name here because
he getting low he be getting dubs like
regular dubs just like every damn near
two days like dubs yeah the most the
most ill [ __ ] i was i was just on
instagram i didn't even know sweetie was
dropping new music and [ __ ] how long i
was like this [ __ ] drank was in
this video
sweetie like my wife's favorite rapper
is [ __ ]
she's like hey she we should put this
all she's like i can't even hear what
the [ __ ] he's saying it sounds like he's
whispering
too that's the code three
incredible and then all black i'm black
shout out to all black he's on the
project
um yeah all black i think is
bringing a lot of energy out of the bay
that is uh necessary for sure
all black because i feel like we have
the same belly you know what i'm saying
so i see all black i'm like yo me and
you were built the same way buddy yeah i
mean like i respect that you know put
put on for the dad bods one time for the
one time
um what's obviously the the uh joint
album is out but what's next for you
on the on the solo tip is gonna be a
solo project the vessel project what's
next
um i don't know it depends because i'm
i'm gonna drop the myself in the
somersault but
if me and vezo finish the tape before
then but it depends though because me
and vino's dropping the tape too so
is the bino tape uh wrapped up we about
to
finish it probably tomorrow how many how
many records are on the beno tape
i don't know i can't remember how many
he did so i think he got like four or
five but i worked fast so
that should be down tomorrow have you
ever been around an artist that works as
fast as you besides him besides your
brother
or that can keep up with you
yeah that's fair hey tk how many songs
you say he got
[ __ ] on this like 1300 or some [ __ ] in
the in the can
he got more than that he probably had
that when i was out the first time i had
that damn near [ __ ]
i don't know where none of them songs is
that thousands
thousands is there anything going on
with it like any any update with him as
far as like when
you know is any any sort of light
you know what's crazy is uh the last
time i saw you we're just kind of
talking about like how
you know you have a lot of um sons in
the l.a
scene as far as just sonically right and
you were gone for a long time so
it was very easy for people to
thrive pretty much with with variations
of what some might call your style right
do you feel like since you've been home
you've been getting the credit and the
uh you know i feel like you've been
getting the notoriety because like i
said you're the hotter
but you have you felt the credit in the
you know the respect you deserve from
your you know from the industry and from
your peers
you know in l.a not in l.a from other
other people though mainstream artists
and [ __ ]
but not the ones from out here i don't
know why
i mean it's a company a couple but who
don't talk about like
uh what was the one thing that when like
when you and drake had that first
conversation did he kind of tell you
like what song it was that caught his
attention or what like what he was
[ __ ] with that you had out at the
time
impatient that was the one yeah cause he
turned that song into a damn near his
song
that's fair [ __ ] draco saying they don't
even sound like you
think it's the same thing nobody know
they be telling me you're making asian
too all right [ __ ] this is a free stuff
he said that's a freestyle it is
jeremiah
oh that's crazy
damn that's crazy i totally forgot about
that record too
jesus that's what he's doing these beats
like
not believe me that's why he gotta hurry
up and do that
he gotta do all the beasts that's like
booming right now
like it's so cold i don't too it's uh
have you tapped him with roddy since
you've been home
i know last time we talked we talked
about how he he blew he blew up while he
was locked up but
yeah i was talking to him
that's a no i feel like that's an
inevitable thing too like whatever album
he's got coming out if he got the
dragon i feel like that'd be crazy for
the city
um any any songs that uh we don't know
about that you're sitting on that you
you can kind of like you know
like without i mean look there you got a
drake feature so it doesn't get it
doesn't get bigger than that unless
unless you tell me you got the whole
feature you know what i mean which i'm
not even sure is bigger than the drake
feature to be
100 honest shout out to jay-z but
they're right there you know what i mean
who oh zuna oh you got the ozuna joint
the [ __ ] i see you about to be in puerto
rico
bros can you go can he said the paisa
dance
i think pisces mexico right that's
mexicans i don't know
care can you uh like are you allow are
you are you still on um
papers or you like can you move but i
think i would go out there
i'm saying like you're allowed to move
around like freely
yeah you got to go to puerto rico to
shoot the video
he's a shout out to ozuna i know he's um
he's opening the cookies in puerto rico
with with burner
uh ralphie with you man like what's next
for you uh you got a
solo project
but [ __ ] i got like a lot of projects
out with like no i mean like coming soon
like coming in
coming soon yeah the next [ __ ]
type [ __ ] and then i got other [ __ ] with
like
make sense when these who get coverwards
and [ __ ] yeah i know you were just
talking about how you were like super
tapped in with some of the young dudes
at stockton
do you think stockton's kind of going to
be like the next wave to hit out of or
out of cali
yeah i think i just need my like ear
from me getting out of jail and just
jumping into the streets you feel me you
know i like a couple you know
just going on instagram seeing like it
needs to be going crazy
um the company's in the bay though too
they go crazy too
yeah that's why you're at i think race
might have started
um what is uh
you know give me a kind of a perspective
from both of you let's say 10 years from
now
you know what y'all want y'all legacy to
be for the last for the next decade
like what do y'all what do you want
somebody to say about draco about
ralphie like
i just want [ __ ] to know like we're
the truth we can rap we've been getting
money
since being getting money was getting
money like [ __ ] no we didn't
like we just we've been doing this [ __ ]
we made this [ __ ] cool so i want [ __ ]
to like they need to know
that's why that's what our fans be going
so hard for us no cat
they know like since they've been
watching us we've been going crazy
yeah hey look the uh you posted a
picture
this guy posted the pictures of
[ __ ] getting draco tattooed on
their head
yeah that's what i'm saying because they
know they know the truth the real fans
where does that do you uh obviously you
have to follow that fan right
that's that gotta get to follow like
the head is different level of yeah
but then it's like when i told everybody
i just wanted to see who had the stink
team today it was 50 [ __ ] i'm
like damn
i gotta follow all 50 of them did you
follow all 50.
draco in the face though but the draco
on the face when you saw that tattoo
when you saw that tattoo were you like
impressed or scared because that's kind
of scary
fans be hyped like that that's some
insane clown posse [ __ ] if we're being
100 percent honest
yeah like when you see a fan get your
actual name tattooed on their [ __ ]
face
that can go like either way it could be
like yo i'm gonna have to block this
person because that's a little scary and
i don't know
or yeah like how like when you saw that
how did you like like how did you
feel that's crazy i mean that's just
like i ain't never seen that one before
that's one for the record the type of
[ __ ] who was drunk really on some draco
[ __ ]
and just like just just a weirdo like
that dude loves you
yeah yeah on some [ __ ] like weird type
does he get free does he get free
hey does he get free merch like free
like hey look the show's
in your city we'll make sure you get in
all right
that should be his backstage pass for
the rest of his life
like hey man to do the you you'll be a
milwaukee performer this [ __ ]
yeah yo the guy with the draco tattoos
back back he might be at perkins we
ain't [ __ ] winning
he cool though
[Music]
oh no he might be police yeah that
tattoo was uh
it was interesting to get in
are you starting to uh think about you
know touring now that shit's starting to
open up i've been seeing a lot of tours
get announced for like october
november are you are you uh is that
where your head is
you know i feel like you could do a tour
and it'd be crazy yeah
i'm ready have you been able to like
move around
outside of cali much
shout out to miami man miami's no state
tax
no state tax great strip clubs great
food
the water's warmer you go to [ __ ]
santa monica
freeze your [ __ ] ass off getting into
that ocean and you
might step on a heroin needle you go to
venice beach you're definitely stepping
on a heroin needle
you're gonna walk into some human [ __ ]
they done turned that [ __ ] to some third
world country [ __ ] this tents lined up
everywhere and [ __ ] i'm like bro this is
bro
[ __ ] got some money and got went crazy
yeah you said have you been to venice
recently draco bros tents everywhere bro
it is ins i rode my bike through there
about a month ago man when i tell you
it is like
it's it is it's like [ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] skid row bro on the
water all these [ __ ] is living
on the beach for free and they going
crazy
stay away man everybody fighting
up here they [ __ ] in buckets
they are i saw some [ __ ] [ __ ]
she was [ __ ] bro some
homeless lady was [ __ ] in a bucket
bro i'm on my bike look over she's
[ __ ] in a paint bucket i said oh
hell no people walking by with their
kids and [ __ ]
and venice beach was always like kind of
you know different but now it's [ __ ]
you all on heroin they just got watched
afterwards
for sure it wasn't busting them yeah
they got their edd and they bought
camping supplies
downtown [ __ ] [ __ ] got little hondas
out there and parked down there if
[ __ ] out there
living yeah you guys i'm obviously being
uh you know
from l.a like the homeless [ __ ] is so
crazy out here
it's it's getting um it's getting almost
unbearable they're getting comfortable
i don't know how to [ __ ] lay in that
country would you guys ever leave la
and like obviously like like as far as
just getting another place to live in a
different
different state just not as la kind of
crazy you know i'm not
i'm not even talking about the street
[ __ ] i just mean it's a lot of smoker
[ __ ]
smokers we talking crack
meth type of [ __ ] out here
just moving weird out here i don't even
know no
you guys [ __ ] with snowfall oh that's my
[ __ ] i should remind me like some back
in the day type right now [ __ ]
yeah yeah you watch no fault draco i
haven't got
i never got to get in it
that [ __ ] is crazy this [ __ ] is like
it's like a freeway it's like
it feels like it was loosely based on
freeway rick ross's story
right whoever wrote it they kind of
wrote it john singleton right now oh
yeah oh that's why
rest in peace
hey um draco what is something that's in
your playlist right
that everyone would be extremely
surprised by
a non-rap song how about that
you're gonna pull out the adele the
[ __ ]
then some nickelback
oh probably topic breaking me
okay that's my b [ __ ] right
[Music]
trevor daniel that sound like the
[ __ ] just got drafted by the
jaguars
[Music]
is it is that a country singer pop scene
uh trevor daniel
[Music]
um
who's uh a non-rapper someone who you're
not affiliated with professionally that
you would love to
collaborate with it's a little kind of
random
yeah like like a like no no no no no not
like let's take rappers out of the
equation
songwriter somebody who who you would
want to work with them we might not
[Music]
expect
your son thought that was hilarious your
nephew thought that was hilarious
he hit the giggle he said all right 21
a lot of that uh you know i don't know
what they call it [ __ ] you know
14 15 year old i mean that's probably
most of your friends probably 14 50 year
old white kids anyway
they already there anyway you know what
i'm saying
well a cold day in hell is out uh the
joint project
uh you got a whole lot of [ __ ] coming
[ __ ] every day i yeah near put every
song i record on instagram so people
just be going on my instagram
just a charlie ball that [ __ ] so they
got to wait i'll be trying to just show
[ __ ] they can't [ __ ] watch
bro you said archive yeah
yo that should be happening sometimes
you'll be reading some [ __ ] phonetically
he'll be like
you said how you think it's pronounced
right right right right right right
and then draco you got your [ __ ] coming
solo for the summer
tape and a vezo tape
you're doing a tape of blue box
is that uh damn that's crazy those guys
got the best sports references in their
bars
they got all the sports bars you know
what i'm saying
what did you say they said there's some
[ __ ] they said some [ __ ] you had only
one good year jay cutler
i says and then you really got to be
into it
yeah they got football bars galore
that's crazy
it's like yeah them dudes
he'd be on time too yeah did he say no
cat yeah he's been saying that all the
time
and then hopefully we get the we get the
drake video
by the way soulja boy came through and i
asked him about the name draco
i said hey look man i said i had draco
the ruler up here
this happened today i said uh
i didn't bring up the jail [ __ ] because
i mean you know but i said like i had
draco the ruler up here
that's obviously his name he's had that
name for a long time
uh he's not too fond of you having
called yourself big draco
he said my name is deandre
cortez whatever his last name is so he
said
draco the last three the last three
letters of his first name in the first
two
oh you've heard it before okay okay i'm
just letting you know that that's
he ain't never been there
why he didn't call himself that back in
the day you should have been drinking
it's different you know who i am though
it's nice
and he so you're saying he knows who you
are very aware yeah okay okay okay
so the draco the ruler and big draco
collaboration will never happen
the way you just said it and hit the
vape
850 bands right you get the video in the
verse
video you get to look cool you get all
the street [ __ ]
actually in the background he got a
record right now you know he said you
know he seemed like he's
at least the last time i saw him was he
when he was on his uh
the gucci headband wave where he was
talking crazy to everybody
he can ride tick tock right now that's
just you know everybody
chance again but you got to make it
count do you have a tick tock account
yeah i can't imagine you like um
actually
like like do you have someone who does
the tick tocks for you or you
know i made like a couple tick tocks i
really only been
kind of like trying to be on i've been
kind of watching it now because they've
been having that little she [ __ ] going
around
the west like i just want people to be
arguing because they know i
i've been saying that [ __ ] forever wait
i'm sorry uh clarify what you just said
tick tock challenge like everybody be on
there
saying sheesh oh okay
have you um are you
are you uh would you ever have a dance
to one of your songs
or do you like if the fans create
something like that you run with it but
you they made it
right i just can't imagine you doing
like a [ __ ]
look at our videos
i just i just can't imagine you're doing
a tick tock challenge like you know what
i'm saying like
a challenge
um the double xl freshman cover now i
wouldn't consider you a freshman right
but
it feels like that's something that you
know you deserve to kind of get a look
on is that something that uh
you're interested in or not really
though
because they should have been did it
they know what time it is
[Music]
[Music]
yo shout out to hip hop weekly it was
great magazine because there always has
so many grammatical errors in it
it's like it was like dave may's dumb
ass was writing the [ __ ] himself
by the way i actually own like five
percent of hip-hop weekly so shout out
to hip-hop weekly hopefully it comes
back soon so you know
shout out to my guy clarence barnes
uh anyway yo i appreciate y'all coming
through we're gonna have you guys you
know uh kick some bars and [ __ ] in a
little bit so that would be a separate
youtube video
and um cabarro like i don't know like
just i just i just want to flex like
it's mine
in a tick time
i'm not even lying this man threw this
money on the floor outside on the
sidewalk
and was kicking it like it was a soccer
ball
and i was like bruh yeah that's crazy
and if i'm trying to do the math in my
head
as far as how fast you record verses
and how much you charge for verses and
how small amount of time it took you to
make that money imagine when you walk
out the studio you was in there an hour
and you come out with like a hundred
bands
worth of features ready you know what
i'm saying that's impressive man
that's impressive well i'm looking
forward to uh what y'all got the rest of
the year man
and go check out a cold day in hello